some say
you
had many like strong aspirations of one
day being a president was that true like
you wanted to be president one day
you know yes and no you get you become
the governor people start talking about
you that way
i wasn't saying it they were talking
about me that way
and uh
look anybody who's up that high in
politics looks at the next position so i
wouldn't say i wasn't interested in it
but let me say this i honestly thought
and this might sound like but
for the first time in my life i was in a
position governor chief executive of a
big state with real power to actually do
real stuff for people i'd spent six
years in congress i think i was a good
congressman but you don't have a lot of
influence there especially when you're
new and young it's seniority has a lot
to do with it and it's also a collective
body so it's not like you can just do
things
now suddenly for the first time in my
life i've got power i was the youngest
in my family so i never carved the
turkey or you know my my fat luck
harvester give thanksgiving dinners now
here's something i'm the governor of
illinois i could actually do stuff if i
wanted to if i was pursuing a
presidential path
and that was my big aspiration i
wouldn't have ruffled feathers i
wouldn't have pushed the stuff that i
was pushing i'd have played nice with
all the political leaders and they'd
have been happy to kick me out illinois
and run me for president
if i was doing it that way frankly with
obama do all due respect
all show
no go i mean he gives a good speech
there's not a lot of substance there no
really achieved no real achievements for
people and he became the first black
president of american history a great
opportunity for our country to bring us
further together on race but he left in
his wake a country further divided on
race because he played
politics with that issue and he's made
our country a less united place in fact
a more divisive place at an angrier
place he could have been a great
president and he it up in my
opinion because he wouldn't invest
political capital in it so to answer
your question maybe the mistake i made
if it was being president only was that
i was truly trying to get stuff done for
people and and use my power that way
instead of just being nice with all the
politicians courting people and going up
higher maybe that would have been the
better play and i would have gone to the
white house and not the house so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you